add 80s turn on c-span
Washington Journal continues we welcome
back a bill Schneider the book is titled
standoff how America became uncover
nerble what's the premise behind this
well we have a president who governs by
dividing America that's how he got
elected that's how he governs and we
have a constitutional system that
enables his opponents to block things
that the president wants to do so you
put those two elements together and you
gotta say you good gridlock let's begin
where the book begins you write the
following on November 8th 2016 American
voters did an astonishing thing they
elected a president of the United States
who most voters 61% did not think was
qualified to serve as president and then
you pose these two questions how did
that happen and how did we get from John
F Kennedy to Donald J Trump or as I say
from Camelot to Game of Thrones which is
what's happened it was a long process it
took over 50 years but what really has
happened is that interests which always
dominate politics they're still there of
course divisions of interests have given
way to divisions of values questions of
right and wrong divisions of interests
like the the split between business and
labor that dominated politics back in
the 1930s they can be negotiated they
can be compromised divisions of values
were about matters are right and wrong
and particularly if they're about
identity politics those things can't be
negotiated or compromised they produce
an impasse you wrote in the book that
during the lead-up to the 2000 campaign
that was one election that you really
did not know who the winner was going to
be that's right
what about 2016 2016 we knew who the
winner was gonna be it was just wrong
everyone assumed including apparently
James Comey that it was going to be
Hillary Clinton and then all of a sudden
kaboom here comes Donald Trump who wins
the electoral college not the popular
vote for the electoral college it was a
remarkable election Donald Trump lost
California by over 4 million votes he
won the closely contested States there
about a dozen of them by just a very
tiny margin but it doesn't matter how
big your margin is if you win by even
one vote you get all of the state's
electoral votes in almost every state so
he he worked this
system he knew how to work the system
maybe with a little help from the
Russians that hasn't been proved yet do
you think he runs for re-election yes
because he never gives in he never gives
up
yes he's already running for reelection
I think he's already filed as a
candidate for re-election this is also
from the book the Trump movement is the
latest manifestation of resistance by
would you called the old America the
gradual and halting rise of the new
America faced resistance every step of
the way it is a standoff the potential
for gridlock is built into the US
Constitution it is because the writers
of the founders of the Constitution did
not want a strong government they wanted
a weak government they associated strong
government with tyranny they just fought
a revolution against the king the first
constitution even before the actual
constitution the Articles of
Confederation produced the government
that was so weak it couldn't even
function so they had to replace it throw
it out that we know and replace it with
the Constitution what that means is it's
very hard to get things done in our
system of government the president's not
all that powerful as president Trump is
now discovering he's facing resistance
by the courts on issues like the
dreamers by States which were an open
rebellion against the federal government
California is challenging the President
on dreamers they're challenging him on
sanctuary cities the states are divided
over this and the Congress this is a
Republican Congress they won't give him
the money to fund the border wall so
that there are always blockages built
into the system it was designed not to
work very well but you know what it does
work what is required to make it work is
a crisis every time we have a crisis our
system functions supremely well like
after 9/11 like after the financial
crisis then things can get done who do
you think which president really shaped
the modern presidency
Franklin Roosevelt he gave he brought
more power to the presidency more power
to Washington course conservatives and
Republicans believe he destroyed the our
system of government by making him much
too big and too expensive but Franklin
we said you said shape the modern
presidency that would be Franklin
Roosevelt one other point from the book
and you're talking about the state of
the Republican Party quote the
Republican Party has become the party of
angry white men
what are they angry about political
correctness while working-class men see
political correctness as a way of
shutting them out president obama seemed
to be a symbol of political correctness
yes he was a political correctness
irritates them because this constituency
mostly working-class white men they feel
disrespected and in many ways they are
because the Democratic Party has come to
be committed to the cause of diversity
and inclusion diversity does not include
them white men and inclusion isn't
doesn't mean anything for them they see
the rise of the minority groups of
working women even the me2 movement is
somehow threatening to them and they're
really angry about it this movement this
backlash started to emerge in the 60s at
the same time that the new America
became evident that is groups that had
always been marginalized suddenly found
their voice educated professionals
African Americans immigrants gays in the
1960s there was a ferocious backlash
against that that movement on the right
it started with Barry Goldwater and then
George Wallace and then Richard Nixon
and then Ronald Reagan who brought
religious conservatives into the
Republican Party there was a fierce
backlash the changes of the 60s happened
all over the Western world but in the
United States more than any other
country they faced a ferocious and
lasting backlash our guest is Bill
Schneider the book is titled stand up
you spent how many years at CNN 18 and a
half if you look at the Democratic and
Republican Party and civil war might be
too strong of a term but there really is
some real infighting between within the
Democratic Party certainly between the
left and the more moderate wing of the
Democratic Party and under in the
Republican Party how is that going to
play out in 2018 well first of all
there's nothing new about that there's
always been infighting my god I remember
the 1960s you had right-wing Democrats
led by Wallace and revolt against the
party establishment and you had
left-wing Democrats in revolt against
the party establishment over civil
rights well know that civil rights the
party establishment embraced civil
rights they were revolt over the Vietnam
War so it's not more intense now I don't
think it's more intense than it was then
remember the
kaga know if you remember you're a young
man remember the Chicago reading about
the Chicago convention in 1968 there was
blood on the streets and Republicans
were pretty brutal they split wide open
over Barry Goldwater even Richard Nixon
these divisions are inherent in our
party system so on the Republican side
we saw what happened last week with the
farm bill there's a lot of people saying
that speaker Ryan is now a lame duck you
have some divisions on immigration
within the Republican Party and the
Republicans with a relatively narrow
number in the house and an even closer
number in the US Senate to retain
majority in 2019
that's true you got to remember
something about American politics we
have a system of independent political
entrepreneurs every politician in
Congress is in business for himself or
herself they're interested in their own
careers their own advancement and they
really don't the party can be helpful
that the party can be hurtful but they
don't necessarily fall in line but
behind a single party leader even if
it's the president of the United States
and on the Democratic side of the aisle
you have the progressives well you have
the progressives led led by Bernie
Sanders who you mentioned before you
also have the the more moderate Clinton
wing of the party so where does that
leave the Democrats in 2018 it leaves
them basically united by one thing
Donald Trump they all hate Donald Trump
and they mean to stop Donald Trump
that's what unites the Democratic Party
but do they have a message the message
is stop Donald Trump but is that enough
to get Democrats to the polls this year
yes in 2020 of course they're going to
have to come up with a candidate and
then it's going to be a little bit
tougher but this year it'll be a
negative election on it'll be referendum
on Donald Trump just like the 2010
midterm was in a referendum on Barack
Obama and so was 2014 midterms are
always like that and so what will happen
this year what will happen to the House
Senate well I think the Democrats have a
good chance nothing is certain in
politics look we don't know what's going
to happen with North Korea the economy
is steaming along but the odds are the
Democrats will narrowly take control of
the house I think it'd be much more
difficult for them to take control of
the Senate once they take control of the
house they're going to try to stop
everything Donald Trump enhance the
and they marry very well may be inclined
to impeach him that could divide the
party as well sure leader Pelosi stepped
down or do you think she should remain
and potentially serve as Speaker that's
really up to the House Democrats if they
are satisfied with our leadership and
the Democrats win a signal victory I
think she'll stay in but if they're they
do disappointingly this year of the
they'll be pressure on her to step down
just like what happened to Newt Gingrich
in 1998 when the Republicans did badly
in the midterm election and Gingrich
resigned I don't think she should
necessarily resign but she might want to
step down one other point from the book
quote public opinion remains a
controlling factor in American politics
a system of limited government is
particularly important when the country
is a president with the temperament of a
megalomania I do think that mr. Trump
has the temperament of a megalomaniac
I watched carefully you probably did to
that cabinet meeting in June 2017 when
he went around the room and each member
of the cabinet was called on to say
something wonderful and agile Ettore
about the president and then he said
something about himself it really was
very nervous making it was kind of like
North Korea that was to me the clear
sign of a megalomaniac well we have that
video which will show in just a moment
but let's get to your phone calls first
Debbie is joining us from Wilson North
Carolina
good morning Democrats line good morning
first of all I just want to say to you
thank you for engaging with the callers
that's rare Thank You mr. Snyder good
morning and thank you for your book
haven't read it Wow America become
uncomfortable I think you're right we're
we've got a president that's an office
that's not really taking a look at the
people he's out for self and the parties
are out for self like how do we really
get here and where do we move forward on
this
I think people in America just need to
stick to what's real and just please
engage me for a minute people need to
just stick to what's real follow their
hearts you know you treat people the way
you want to be treated we're all
brothers and sisters in Christ and and I
just needed to say that and I hope we
as a nation can get back to loving one
another and one more thing this is a
comment why don't you all air the
beautiful wedding yesterday in London
thank you Demi let me go back to your
with us hung up do you want to respond
well that's what everyone wishes for but
remember you know this country is
bitterly divided I had a student in the
class who once raised his hand and said
is this the most divided we've ever been
as a country and I said you know young
man we did once have a civil war
three-quarters of a million Americans
died many from starvation and disease in
the Civil War that was a terrible
experience we're nowhere close to that
right now but I'd say this is the most
divided we've been since the Civil War
what will take to unite us typically is
some sort of overwhelming national
crisis in a crisis we function very very
well we did that in the depression we
did that after 9/11 we did that in the
financial crisis in recent years give us
a crisis in our system of government
works very well without a crisis it's
hard to get anything done and Debbie
thanks for the call to answer your other
question we are a public affairs Network
certainly there was no shortage
yesterday in places to watch the Royal
Wedding and we appreciate your kind
comments about the c-span hosts we'll go
to Tim in Griffith Indiana good morning
Democrats line good morning mr.
Schneider you earlier you mentioned
something about you know you said that
things got bloody and that's I'm a
retired police officer and I guess what
I'm thinking is I'm worried that same
thing is going to happen if Donald Trump
shuts down this investigation if he
manages to get this thing shut down that
I mean seriously I worry that there's
gonna be a big basket backlash and it
could get bloody again I want to know do
you think that's headed that way 218
performing and his response quick
question for you do you think that the
president preemptively is trying to
discredit robert muller and the
investigation based on his tweets and
comments Oh without a doubt
I mean it's so obvious than it gets I am
watching you know we're all watching the
lines play out on TV you know it's it's
it's that obvious and like I say there I
feel that we're gonna see a lot of blood
if he shuts this down because people are
not going to stand for it yeah thank you
and you were quick to say yes as well to
that question
well yes I don't use the word bloody
that's a little too gruesome I'm not
sure we're gonna break down into another
Civil War
but I do think there'll be a lot of
anger and resistance as there was when
Richard Nixon shut down the Independent
Counsel investigation back in the 1970s
there will be a huge backlash it will be
extremely controversial there'll be a
lot of pressure for impeachment in the
Democratic Party and it'll what happens
is when the word impeachment comes up it
takes over the agenda nothing else
matters remember in 1998 when Bill
Clinton attacked the terrorist
encampments in Sudan and Afghanistan the
press covered that by saying well he's
just wagging the dog because he's just
trying to avoid this scandal of the
Monica Lewinsky story
well impeachment takes over the whole
agenda buddy is not a word that I would
use it wasn't bloody even then but I
would say that there will be nothing
else happening except discussions of
impeachment for about a year if that is
what happens and if that does happen is
there a concern that the Democrats could
overreach the way the Republicans did
with Bill Clinton yes at a price yes
that could be that could very well
happen and the most important thing is I
think if Democrats decide to run their
campaign in 2018 by pledging that they
will impeach the president as soon as
they take a majority in the House that's
going to be extraordinarily divisive
because it's going to produce a backlash
among Trump supporters and Republicans
we're going to come out in huge numbers
to protect their president the Democrats
may wish for impeachment but I don't
think that's a wise issue for them to
run on it all begins in New Hampshire
and Iowa our next callers from Derry New
Hampshire can good morning Republican
line good morning they call again
the boy tonight so you don't have a good
view on Sunday I have a good comment and
the question the comment is I really get
tired of hearing the argument that Trump
lost the popular vote because that's not
the system you know that and I know that
we all know that and I really wish that
goes away because the system doesn't
work that way we especially when to look
at counties in America I want to say
somewhere around 20 music sir
Trump won all but about 150 of those
counties in America I think that was a
statement of the American people to say
we were and chemical and we needed
someone that doesn't ban to come in from
the outside and not clean up and yes I
first I thought he was kind of a bully
but then I realized he's a bully frauds
so that's I think why the change on that
one but a question is when you bring up
the crisis yes it does take a crisis
September 11th Pearl Harbor I think you
mentioned that but wonderful we were in
at the time with Hillary Clinton and the
economies and the Loretta Lynch's and
you know the cave and all that it would
not be considered crisis all the
crunching go on is that not a crisis
that why we make a change to change that
to get back to America what we're about
what make that's great thank you Ken
we'll get a response I'm not sure I
understood the last part because it was
a little bit garment he's on it on the
phone and yeah I do yeah the way I like
to put it is Donald Trump won by the
rules there's no question that he won by
the rules the Electoral College is are
the rules and it's going to be very
difficult ever to change those but
without a popular majority he didn't
have a great mandate and we always look
at an election and say did he get a
mandate I do think Trump got a mandate
he got a mandate for a very very simple
reason his election was so unexpected
the fact that he did something that
nobody expected to happen he won the
election by the rules
gave him a sense of momentum and he gave
him a real base in politics that I think
is where is very true the book is called
standoff
how America became uncover nerble and
joining us here in Washington is author
Bill Schneider formerly with CNN and now
teaching at UCLA and George Mason and
George Mason University let's go to Jeff
in Crofton
Nebraska good morning Republican line
good morning
mr. Snyder is a quick question on and
maybe comment the it's funny that you
went into Kennedy's probably the most
corrupt family that I think America has
ever had as it was especially John in
the head but but when we go back to the
the dossier and and how cNN has been
complicit with proving that and they use
CNN report when they went to the FISA
Court and all these other things that
the last caller mentioned with the
Hillary and call me and Loretta Lynch
and all these people is this not a
crisis are we not in a crisis right now
well the way you determine whether it's
a crisis is by looking at public opinion
and finding out if there's a huge demand
from the public to do something anything
to get us out of this mess when that
happens the government clicks into shape
all the divisions disappear Congress
acts and we do something that's what
happened after the financial crisis and
it got President Obama's economic
stimulus plan passed even though it was
very controversial because we had to do
something that's what happened after
9/11 that's what's happened repeatedly
but the real test of a crisis is is
there an overwhelming demand from the
public that government do something when
the elected officials feel that kind of
demand they act they stop blocking
things have you look in the monitor and
tell our audience this is the
Pennsylvania congressional map the old
map as it looked like before the state
Supreme Court had redistricting the the
18 congressional districts in
Pennsylvania so this is the old map and
this is the new map which was a factor
in the of the the primary that took
place this past week how significant is
this for the House of Representatives
very significant because it raises
questions
whether the Republicans are trying have
tried to remain in power through
gerrymandering through designing
districts you know voters are supposed
to choose their elected officials but in
gerrymandering elected officials choose
their voters there are self designed
districts that are intended to keep
someone in office either a member of a
particular party or a particular member
of Congress it's an outrageous system
everyone agrees with that it happens
every 10 years and that's why the 2020
congressional elections state the state
elections rather are going to be very
important because they are the ones who
draw the district lines and put on your
history had who was Elbridge was it Gary
or Jerry was I think it's pronounced at
the time Elbridge Gerry but it's become
gerrymandering he was a member of
Congress I think way back in the early
18th census it's the Massachusetts and
they designed a district to protect him
I think then it was Federalist versus
Democrat Republicans he was protected by
giving by getting a district with a lot
of his friends and neighbors but it was
an oddly shaped district and a newspaper
cartoonist drew a outline of the
district from a map and it looked very
much like a salamander so they nicknamed
the district that gerrymander that so
back to your phone calls a dick is
joining us Albuquerque New Mexico
Democrats line with Bill Schneider go
ahead please Thank You mr. Schneider for
your honest appraisal of what's going on
in this country today I believe we are
in a crisis right now with this
president I I just I just wake up every
morning look at the news and I get sick
to my stomach i I just you know I just
can't believe it I have another contest
- that has nothing to do with this but
it does have to do with the Texas
Massacre the latest one you know as a
country are going to have to wake up to
the fact that not everyone should be
walking around with an ar-15 and two
banana clips takes
the other I understand that this kid
didn't have that I also think that you
know the school bears some
responsibility his kid shows up school
every day with a black trench coat on
and a Nazi pen
tape do it and no one thought it
necessary just an avid talk with his kid
it it's just irresponsible thank you
we'll get a response dick there is an
epidemic of school shootings they've
increased at a rapid pace this year that
could very well in fact it is shaping up
as a national crisis the issue of guns
and school shootings have become the
number one issue to most Americans right
now they want something done that shows
the evidence of becoming a crisis
exactly the way I described it where
voters are telling elected officials and
everyone who will listen to them we have
to do something about this not
necessarily gun control that could be
part of it but they want something done
about this mass epidemic of school
shootings and this is the headline from
the Washington Post
20:18 has been deadlier for school
children than service members there have
been 22 school shootings since January
including of course what happened in
parkland Florida on February 14 and
remember that just about everyone has
been to school has family in school and
this is something that spreads across
the whole country because even in areas
that have not experienced this sort of
terrible violence students are afraid to
go to school they're nervous they're
wondering every day if they go to class
are they gonna be shot someone gonna
come in and kill them well one other
number to put on the table since
Columbine 216 thousand students have
been exposed to school shootings that's
right
that's all awful lot of students of
course there are a lot more than that in
school but they're all nervous they're
all terrified and that shows all the
indications of becoming a national
crisis bill senator you mentioned
something earlier and we have the video
from June of last year this is the
cabinet meeting that took place at the
White House let's watch and listen so I
think what we'll do most of you know
most of the
around the room but I'm going to start
with our for my surprise event where's
our vice president otherwise surprise
today
there he is and now may be stuck with
Mike and we'll just go around and just
you name your position and then it will
ask these folks to go back and have a
good day and we're going to discuss the
various reports Mike Thank You mr.
president
and just greatest privilege of my life
to serve a vice president to the
president is keeping his word to the
American people and assembling a team
that's bringing real change real
prosperity real strength that foundation
thank you Mike let's present I'd strike
to be here and celebrate this group we
are receiving as you know I'm not sure
the rest of you fully understand the
support but law enforcement all over
America they have been very frustrated
they are so thrilled that we have a new
idea that we're going to support them
and work together to properly lawfully
fight the rising crime that we're seeing
it's anonymous and it's Mabel to serve
you in that regard you can set the exact
right message and is being responded the
response is fabulous around the country
great success including ms-13 they're
being thrown out in record numbers and
rapidly and they're being depleted
they'll all be gone pretty soon or
something you're right Jeff thank you
very much
Alice mr. president my privilege here
we honored and I want to thank you for
keeping your commitment to the American
workers this week is a full schedule for
you focusing on the American worker
we're very excited at the Department of
Labor and the apprenticeship program
that we're gonna be announcing I think
is gonna make a real difference so thank
you thank you congratulations mr.
president honored to be on the team this
last week I had the great privilege to
represent America at China at the green
energy ministerial good timing
they needed to hear why America was
stepping away from the Paris Accord and
they did and then America is not
stepping back but we're stepping into
place and sending some messages that
we're still gonna be leaders into when
it comes to the climate but we're not
gonna be held hostage to some executive
order that was the old thought out so my
hats off to you for taking that stand
and for sending a clear message around
the world that America is gonna continue
to lead in the area of energy thank you
June 12th of 2017 in the full event
available on our website at c-span org
bill Schneider in your book you refer to
this as Dear Leader
why because it looks very much like what
people do in North Korea when they talk
about the Dear Leader president I guess
as Prime Minister Kim or President Kim
of North Korea it's embarrassing
lots of people were just humiliated by
this exposure to a president who laps up
flattery he solicits flattery you know
there's something unusual about Donald
Trump he's not like any other president
for one particular reason he's a divider
he won the election by dividing the
country the country was already divided
but he he exploited that division he saw
an opportunity he's a good businessman
he saw the opportunity of exploiting the
division and that's what got him elected
and he governs as a divider remember he
succeeds four presidents in a row each
of whom promised to heal the division in
the country the first George Bush was
kinder and gentler he got fired after
one term Bill Clinton was a new Democrat
and the third way he got impeached
George W Bush got elected he
said as a uniter not a divider and
because of the war in Iraq the country
was more bitterly divided than ever and
finally Barack Obama said there's no
liberal America there's no conservative
America there's only in the United
States of America he was wrong
there is a liberal in a conservative
America and what he got was a Tea Party
revolt well Donald Trump was not like
any of his predecessors they all offered
to be healers Donald Trump is anything
but a healer do you think we will hear
more public statements by President
Obama because clearly this president has
done a lot to turn back a lot of the
Obama era regulations and he's been very
critical on a personal level at former
President Obama there's a bitter joke
going around among Democrats that says
if Trump had succeeded Abraham Lincoln
he would reinstate slavery um that's a
very cynical joke but the fact is he
does intend to eradicate everything
Obama accomplished if not Clinton and
Franklin Roosevelt as well and so do a
lot of Republicans agree with that this
is a very big problem we could be into a
period of lurching presidencies a
president from the right like Donald
Trump a president from the left and each
of whom tries to eradicate the legacy of
his predecessor that would be very
dangerous because it would destroy
consensus in the United States our next
caller is joining us from England and
this program is carried on the BBC
Parliament Channel so mark good
afternoon to you and welcome to the
conversation good afternoon
I'm an American living in Britain and I
think back to the time of the founding
fathers when democracy was a weird idea
there was some person in for it in
ancient Greece but it was considered a
weird idea to let everybody have a say
in rule I think where America may be
really going seriously wrong now is is
the whole basis of democracy is that the
majority wins and that gives the person
who won the election the clout to rule
because the majority of people are
behind them now I know my gerrymandering
developed over time and I know why the
Electoral College developed over time
but everybody understands democracy all
over the world as majority rule
and in America we have somebody who is
not did not get the most votes who's the
president so it just it it completely
blows the idea of democracy sky-high
what you have is is is a kind of weird
system of rules where the majority
doesn't rule and it's no wonder that the
president doesn't have backing because
he doesn't represent the most Bunch
no mark thank you and I'm just reminded
twice within eighteen years we had a
president who won but did not win the
popular vote George W Bush in 2000 and
now Donald Trump in 2016 that's right
and I think that really damaged them
when they got elected they did win by
the rules of the electoral college
because the question was did they get
any mandate out of this without majority
support they started off with with very
weak support in Trump's case I've
already said I think he did get
something of a mandate because his
election was so unexpected in the case
of George W Bush in 2000 of course Al
Gore said he didn't agree with the
Supreme Court's decision but he would
abide by it
there was no revolts in the country
there was no rioting in the streets
because Gore gave that important signal
I think what we're eventually joins some
people she did get a mandate he got it
on September 11th 2001 nine months after
he took office that's when he got a
mandate to govern the country not from
the election which he did not get a
majority as an academic this is a
speculative question but I'm going to
ask it to you anyhow had Hillary Clinton
won the presidency with the Republicans
in the House and the Senate what do you
think her first two years would have
been like open political warfare between
the President Clinton in between the
Republican Congress Bill Clinton was
able to deal with the Republican
Congress her husband he was a very
moderate Democrat and a lot of Democrats
are turning against Bill Clinton right
now because of his record but he worked
with Republicans in Congress to get
welfare reform to get the regulation of
Wall Street to get a crime bill that's
now become extremely controversial but
he had to because they had the house
that's right even supported a balanced
budget plan with Newt Gingrich he
decided that the only way you can govern
this country is through compromise you
have to make a deal
it's very cynical
people don't like it but that's what's
mandated really by the Constitution I
remember a tea party voter once
confronted President Clinton and she
said why can't this country be governed
why don't you know why are we in so much
trouble and the President Clinton said
to her
read the Constitution madam it might as
well be called let's make a deal let's
go back to your phone calls Diana is
joining us from Accio Minnesota good
morning Democrats line Bill Snyder here
in our table at the table in Washington
go ahead Diana good morning bill
Schneider I've been a very interesting
conversations you've been having on CNN
and and your work with CNN it was
wonderful I have a question for you
you said that to remember that every
politician is in the business for
himself and that really struck me it
struck a nerve and I just want you to
explain to me what that actually means
it it sheds a pretty dim light on
politicians and I guess I just want you
to expound on that place okay you what I
mean by that is unlike other countries
parliamentary democracies like Britain
or France our politicians are not foot
soldiers in a party army sometimes they
abide by party discipline but they're
not really they don't see themselves
really is there to enforce a party's
rule to enforce party discipline that's
not what they're all about they're all
about advancing their own careers that's
why I say they're all fully independent
political entrepreneurs what that means
is if they're a Republican they will
support a Republican president if they
believe it's in their interest to do so
for to advance their careers but they
will also oppose a Republican president
we see that now among Republicans in
Congress if they think it will hurt
their careers they're very
independent-minded
another viewer from London Simon good
morning good afternoon to you you've
recovered from your wedding over the
weekend thank you to your former caller
for for thanking us we had a lovely day
it was a really really lovely day we're
we're a proud country
it's a pleasure to be on I try to watch
you as often as I can and mr. Schneider
thank you I think this is one of the
first moments after the the 316
presidential election that actually
makes sense where I'm listening to
somebody who's explaining things in a
way that my instinct tells me this is
this is right this is actually right my
question was really this every time the
these awful shootings and massacres in
your schools occur I have I have a sort
of a as business of traditions of the
wrong word I treat out the following
lines and it's basically it's in reply
to the NRA press conference just after
Sandy Hook and the quote that I've tweet
out is the only solution to a bad guy
with a gun is to take away the gun and I
tweeted yesterday that I got a sense
that there was inertia I on Capitol Hill
as far as actually dealing grappling
with this with this with I would say a
crisis I mean if you look at the the
parents in Sandy Hook as far as they're
concerned it's a creates a crisis and of
course politicians we can we can berate
them we can we can love them or whatever
they tend to answer to to things to
political expediency and to cash but
surely public servants should first be
prioritize the safety of the nation's
children above their CVs
or above the fatness of their wallet
wouldn't you think does it not is the
crisis is it not at the point at which
America needs to look long and hard at
the Constitution particularly the Second
Amendment and decide guys it's not fit
for purpose it was written almost 300
years ago in a completely different
climate we are a nation that is healing
there are going to be there's going to
be a certain amount of instability and
people are going to get hold of weapons
that can cause such such a rendus
devastation is the Constitution fits the
purpose is it not time to tackle that
thank you so much for taking my call
Simon thanks for the call and thanks for
tuning in every Sunday we appreciate it
guns there in the Constitution the
Supreme Court has ruled a few years ago
that it's an individual
to possess a gun and it's very difficult
to amend the Constitution I retired
Supreme Court justice recently
recommended that we get rid of the
Second Amendment it's causing too much
trouble
you try that it's a very elaborate
process the the problem is that guns
have a special meaning to a lot of
Americans to a lot of gun owners guns
are a symbol of individual freedom if
someone tries to take away your gun you
instantly become less free and they see
that as a basic protection against an
abusive and tyrannical government I have
been to gun shows and I've heard people
come up to me at gun shows and say if
Jews and Europe had had guns there would
have been no Holocaust
if Africans had had guns that would have
been no slavery well that's kind of
absurd but they honestly believe that
they believe in guns as a ultimate
protection against a tyranny and abuse
of authority and that's what America was
really founded on resistance to
Authority we are a country that was
settled originally by Runaways from
Authority defiance is part of our
culture and there is nothing that
describes Donald Trump as president more
than the word defiance he defies the
press he devised the party leadership he
devised Washington he devised common
decency he is defiant that's something
that's part of the American makeup this
is the headline from the Palm Beach Post
quoting one student when is it going to
stop of course the shooting took place
in parkland Florida on Valentine's Day
Don is joining us Las Cruces New Mexico
or aligned for independence good morning
good morning can you hear me we sure can
go ahead please okay I have youth this
morning outlined the cabinet meeting in
every which everyone basically kowtow to
the president you've talked about his
divisive notes you've talked about you
know he is you know the way he couldn't
controls and governs America and I've
been reading some books one of them is
fascism by merit Madeline Albright
one of those on tyranny 20 lessons from
the 20th century
and the road to on freedom another one
is how democracies I so my
question to you if you saw fascism could
you identify it oh yeah I know where
fascism is I've studied the history of
fascism in Europe in Italy in Germany
and Japan and I know what it is it's of
course a constant danger for any system
that's a democracy to decline into
fascism if there's enough pressure in a
real crisis and we see signs of it even
now in in European countries like Poland
and Hungary I think there is something
that protects Americans from that kind
of deterioration it is our
constitutional order our constitutional
order keeps us from becoming extremists
from having fascists or any extremists
taking over the country our
constitutional order is very powerful it
was written to protect Americans the
American nation the new American nation
from a tyrant but it also protect us
from a megalomaniac because there are
many checks and balances on President
chompin what he does there's a Congress
controlled by his own party that doesn't
always cooperate with him there are
state governments that are in open
defiance of the president there are
courts which are trying to stop what he
wants to do with the dreamers and with
sanctuary cities I mean there are lots
of ways in which you can put up
blockades against what a president wants
to do we are protected I believe by our
constitutional system your thoughts
about the vice president Mike Pence the
vice president I think John Nance Garner
once said it's not worth a pitcher of
warm spit at least we think he said spit
we think it was a little bit more vulgar
I won't go there there might a bit more
vulgar the vice president it's a very
humiliating position because it's
emasculating
he is never his own man he's always
someone else's man now if you were the
vice president United States it sets you
up nicely to be the party's next
presidential nominee after the president
retires or serves two terms and that's
very likely that pence will be the
Republican nominee whenever Donald Trump
leaves office that could well happen but
he rarely wins the only one who did was
George HW Bush because people weren't a
third term for Ronald Reagan a vice
president when he runs for office he has
a problem because he's seen as someone
else's
he pence is Trump's man he will always
be Trump's man just like Hubert Humphrey
was Lyndon Johnson's man and Walter
Mondale was Jimmy Carter's man if you're
someone else's man a lot of voters say
this guy's not independent enough well
in March of last year this is what the
vice president said about President
Donald J Trump boundless energy in an
unshakeable belief in the American
people and in the capacity of all of you
making America great again and it is
deeply humbling I continue for this
small-town boy from across the border in
southern Indiana they have the
opportunity to serve as vice president
of the United States of America and I
want to thank you on behalf of my family
for the first time in a long time I said
it earlier this week we've got a
president with broad shoulders and a big
heart and it's an honor to serve with
him every day
Snyder the vice president the president
well Donald Trump when he was
campaigning he made a deal with
conservatives conservatives basically
said like like Mike Pence
they said we'll support you and we want
you in the White House so that you will
sign whatever legislation the Republican
Congress passes and keep your mouth shut
what they got was a president who did
sign mostly what Republicans passed in
Congress but he won't keep his mouth
shut he embarrasses a lot of Republicans
and we're seeing a cleavage that's new
in American politics we're seeing a
bigger and bigger division by education
the better educated you are right now
the more likely you are to vote
Democratic the wealthier you are the
more likely you are to vote Republican
and when I tell students that someone
raises his hand and says what about
people who are wealthy and well-educated
well they're what sociologists call
cross pressured they're pulled in
different directions if they vote their
economic interests
a Republican that would be Mitt Romney
the Prince of wealth if they vote their
cultural values they're gonna vote
Democratic
that would be Barack Obama the Prince of
education education is now something
much bigger than it ever has been and
better educated voters particularly
Republican voters are leaving the
Republican Party because they can't
stand Donald Trump before I let you go I
want to share with you this is the
headline this morning front page of the
New York Times an extensive piece
co-written by four reporters for the
washer for The New York Times the Trump
inquiry grows to include context in the
Gulf and among the findings in this New
York Times story quote President Trump
accused the FBI on Friday without
evidence of sending a spy to secretly
infiltrate his 2016 campaign for
political purposes even before the
bureau had any inkling of the phony
Russia hoax
in fact FBI agents sent an informant to
talk to two campaign advisers only after
they received evidence that the pair had
suspicious contacts a link to Russia
during the campaign the informant and
American academic who teaches in Great
Britain made contact late that summer
with one campaign advisor George
papadopolis and later with Carter Page
who is also under FBI scrutiny for his
ties to Russia and then there's this the
role of the informant is at the heart of
the newest battle between top law
enforcement officials and president
Trump's congressional allies over the
FBI's most politically charged
investigations in decades no evidence
has emerged that the informant acted
improperly when the FBI asked for help
in gathering information on the former
campaign advisers or that the agents
veered from the FBI's investigative
guidelines and began a politically
motivated inquiry which would be illegal
so that's from the New York Times just a
short while ago the president tweeting
the following let me read it to you
quote things are getting really
ridiculous the failing and crooked but
not as crooked as Hillary Clinton New
York Times has done a long and boring
story indicating that the world's most
expensive witch fund witch hunt has
found nothing on Russia and me and so
now they are looking at at the rest of
the world and again going back to the
headline about contacts in the Gulf and
now refuting what the president was
saying about FBI informants what he's
doing is feeding his bay
your base in politics are the people who
are with you when you're wrong
Donald Trump is wrong very often he's
wrong about a lot of things but there's
a constituency that out there that's
going to stick with him through thick or
thin he knows that he feeds his base
that's why he's such a divisive
president because in order to do that
you've got to divide the country well
there are those people who are going to
be with him there they might be as much
as a quarter of the country not 42%
which is his approval rating there are a
lot of people there who will drop off
very quickly but he has people who
believe him no matter what he says and
he can say the most incredible things he
said were now with the entire
intelligence community with the FBI with
the Justice Department they're all out
to get him well they're certainly
looking into what happened on his
campaign and whether there was anything
improper in his relations with Russia
that's what they're supposed to do but
his base believes exactly what he said
that this is a witch hunt and they will
fight for him to the death the book is
titled standoff now available and the
message is what the message is this
country has never been so divided that
we have a president who's governing us
by dividing us but I in the end I'm
encouraged by the fact that we have a
constitutional order that one that was
written to protect us from tyranny
it'll also protect us from a
megalomaniac author and professor bill
Schneider thanks for stopping by please
come back again okay my pleasure
when we come back we're gonna turn our
attention to North Korea and that
scheduled summit still on the calendar
for June 12th in Singapore and joining
us here is Lisa Collins from the Center
for Strategic and International Studies
c-span's Washington Journal on this
Sunday morning May the 20th we're back
in a moment
[Music]